France is our oldest ally. I want the
people of France to know that the United
States stands with you today, stands
with you tomorrow. Our thoughts and
prayers uh are with the families who've
been uh directly impacted. We grieve
with you. We fight alongside you to
uphold our values, the values that we
share, uh, universal values, uh, that
bind us together as friends and as
allies.
President Obama stating he's got
allegiance to uh, France, but he didn't
go to France. Vice President Kerry
didn't go to the Secretary of State
Kerry didn't go to France. Biden didn't
go to France. The attorney general was
supposed to. He got replaced by the
ambassador. I wonder how much the
Americans really care about what's
happening in the French terror activity
or around the world even as they say
they want to host a summit on terrorism
and how to deal with it. Robert Spencer
is the director of Jihad Watch and he
joins us now via Skype. Robert, what do
you think? The Americans uh supportive
of France?
Uh yeah, from a great distance. I mean
after all Manuel B the prime minister of
France said yesterday that France was at
war with jihadism and radical Islam
which was an extraordinary break from
the politically correct line that all
western leaders have followed that jihad
terrorism has nothing to do with Islam.
Uh, and when asked if he agreed with
this and that the US was also at war
with jihadism and radical Islam, Eric
Holder, the attorney outgoing attorney
general, temporized and said that the US
is at war with those who corrupt the
Islamic State. Uh, and thus showing that
he's going to keep up the politically
correct denial about the fact that
jihadis use the texts and teachings of
Islam to justify what they're doing and
make recruits among Muslims. And unless
and until we confront that fact, we're
never going to be able to counter it.
Okay. So, now we're going to have a
summit sponsored by President Obama on
February the 18th, I think, is the date
that's been bandied around. Wasn't this
the summit that was supposed to take
place back in the fall?
Yes. It was postponed uh apparently out
of some uh concern that it would hurt
the Democrats chances in the elections.
And now that that's all done done with,
it's on again. It's a summit on
countering violent extremism. And so
note here again the denial. Uh violent
extremism is an absolutely null term.
Extreme in what? What if you're
extremely fond of uh TV sitcoms? It's
just a a meaningless phrase that points
up the fact that the United States
government under Barack Obama will not
say that the people who are fighting
against us are Muslims waging jihad in
the cause of Islam in order to impose
Islamic law over the world. There may be
millions of Muslims, there are millions
of Muslims who are not fighting this,
who are not on board with it, but that
does not change the fact that this is
the belief system. this is the ideology
that these people are using and that
we're going to counter it. We have to at
least acknowledge what it is. So, this
is just going to be an absurd pointless
and fruitless exercise.
Well, except that the practical reality
is that people have to deal with this on
an ongoing basis. Robert, you look at
the cities of Boston, Los Angeles, uh
Minneapolis, St. Paul, they have these
uh uh uh countering violent extremism,
CDE programs in place which look at
religion as well as law enforcement but
also include mental health and other
areas. What do you make of these more
grassroots efforts?
Well, I would say that uh without
hesitation that they are absolutely and
100% ineffective. Uh they're just window
dressing. They're just
an attempt to show the public, the
voting public, that something is being
done to counter this threat. But you
take Minneapolis in particular and you
have hundreds of young Muslims from
Minneapolis going first to Somalia to
wage jihad and then now to Iraq and
Syria to wage jihad. And these CBE
programs have been absolutely powerless
to stop even one from going over there.
They are not dealing with the problem as
it really stands because they don't dare
address the fact that these young
Muslims are going over to Iraq and Syria
and Somalia because they believe in
certain principles that are founded in
the Islamic religion and the CE doesn't
dare go into that.
Good point. Okay. Now, switching back to
France, if we could, then you've got uh
the head of um Islamic thought in France
indicating that there's got to be a
separation, an abandonment of the
political Islam. They're trying to
separate the Muslim community, trying to
separate the the religion from the uh
political components. What do you make
of that kind of a statement coming from
a Muslim leader?
I applaud that. I applaud that
wholeheartedly. That's what we need to
see. We need to see the Muslims in the
west saying that the aspects of the
Islam political system which are
authoritarian supremacist and denied
basic rights to women and non-Muslims
and other groups as well have to be
discarded by the Muslims in the west in
a sincere honest ongoing transparent and
inspectable manner and that only by
means of their abandoning those aspects
of Islam and definitively renouncing
them and teaching against them in
Islamic schools. Will it be possible for
Muslims in the aggregate to join into
the the whole fabric of the society in
France, in Western Europe, in Canada and
the US, including the ideas of uh the
freedom of speech and equality of rights
of all citizens before the law. Now,
that's going to be an uphill battle.
It's good to hear them saying that
because most of the time they deny that
there's even a problem. But it's at
least the beginning. If they're saying
that this needs to be done because it is
what needs to be done, it's going to be
very difficult because these things are
rooted in Islamic text and teaching.
They're going to get a lot of resistance
from Muslims who are well aware that
they're rooted in Islamic text and
teaching.
Well, and some of those teachings are
confused. I mean, for instance, the
visualization of Muhammad being illegal,
if you will, in the Muslim belief.
That's a relatively recent phenomenon,
isn't it?
Yeah. But it was mostly Shiites who ever
pictured Muhammad. Sunnis generally
never did. And it's the same kind of
thing that divides Sunnis and Shiites
where Sunnis have shrines to saints and
holy men and Shiites rather have shrines
to saints and holy men where it's
hardline Sunnis generally it's that sort
of thing and think it's idolatry. And
it's the same thing here. They Shiite
might draw Muhammad and a Sunni would
think that idolatry. But the problem
here is not really depicting Muhammad.
The problem is mocking Muhammad. The
problem is that's blasphemy and
blasphemy has the death penalty for
Islam in all sects and schools of
Islamic law. And so to say that there
should not be a death penalty for
blasphemy, that's what we need to see.
But we're not seeing that from any
Muslim group.
No. And in fact, you know, offensive
humor uh and that's what was branded by
this magazine. Offensive humor can be
very useful as a satirical tool to
change sentiment. Do we anticipate that
we'll see more of that?
I hope we see more of that. It's not
about precisely mocking religious
figures. It's about showing that in a in
a free society where people differ on
large questions. We have to be able to
tolerate each other. We have to be able
to tolerate being offended without
resorting to violence in response. And
that point has to be made now or the
freedom of speech and free society
itself will be lost. You know, it's
interesting, Robert. Um, in France, it's
mandated that the nikab is not allowed,
for instance, um, because it hides the
face and those kinds of things in
support. Do you think you could see a
western movement that would voluntarily
remove the nikab?
Voluntarily remove it. You mean some
sort of a Muslim group that said, "We're
not going to wear the nikab."
Yeah, exactly. And and that would speak
to them being uh respectful and
tolerant.
It would be a most welcome development.
were such a group to come to exist, but
none exists like that right now.
Do you think it could come to pass
though in light of the events today,
especially in light that it's already in
France, they don't have to wear them?
Anything can happen in the future. And I
would never say that nothing is is
anything is impossible. But right now,
most of the Muslim groups in the west
are calling for restrictions on the
freedom of speech like your own imam in
Canada in Akmed saying that cartoons and
religious figures ought to be outlawed.
That's the kind of thing we're seeing
from Muslim groups in the wake of this
attack and that's a very unfortunate
thing but not unexpected.
Yeah, good point Robert. Okay, so now
then back to the summit. Um I guess your
point is nothing will be accomplished
until we uh uh acknowledge that this is
the division we need to talk about.
Yes, exactly. And the idea that
political Islam has to be restricted is
and how to restrict it while maintaining
constitutional freedom. That's the kind
of summit he ought to be having. But I
guarantee you 100% without seeing the
agenda or knowing anything about what
they're going to discuss that that's one
thing they're not going to discuss. And
I wouldn't be surprised if the word
Islam is never even mentioned during the
whole of this conference.
Yeah. So you think that they'll talk
about security measures and increased
cooperation and and that kind of
messaging.
Precisely. in cooperation with local
communities, which means in making sure
that counterterror measures don't offend
the local Muslims and that the imams
have no objection to them, which means
no monitoring of mosques, no going into
mosqu and essentially letting them have
cart blanch.
What What about the measures? Um, and we
know that in France already in force are
a a separate judicial uh effort, if you
will, to counter terrorism. We know in
Canada that that's being drawn up. I I
you know and presumably it will address
some of the issues you and I are talking
about. Is the same issue going to come
up at this summit and is it um a
priority for the Americans?
I I don't know that it's a priority for
the Americans. I think that uh what
Obama primarily wants to do with this
summit is show that he's doing
something. That's the main point of the
summit. The way the summit is framed
ensures that it's not going to
accomplish anything. So, it's just
political window dressing.
Is it an opportunity though for
Congress, freshly Republican le, I'll
point out, uh to lead the way in this
dialogue?
Uh that would be a nice development as
well, but freshly Republican le Congress
so far stumbled out of the gate and uh
not shown that it has the will to stand
up to Obama's initiatives. And so, you
know, it's just the same thing that when
it comes to being unwilling to discuss
the root causes of the problem of jihad
terrorism and realistic measures to
limit it, the Republicans are just as
bad as the Democrats. And so, I don't
have high hopes for the newly led, newly
Republican le Congress. But here again,
you know, you never know.
Yeah, absolutely. Well, I never
expected, for instance, to see Netanyahu
and Mundas
together at the forefront of an issue.
So you can have surprises.
Well, you know, uh, France didn't want
Netanyahu to come and when they found
out that he was going to come, they
said, "If you come, we're going to bring
Makamuru as well." And he said, "Well,
you know, do what you're going to do.
I'm going to be there." And so really,
it was just an in kind of a diplomatic
uh uh slap insult by France to bring a
boss there to get back at Netanyahu. now
why they're hostile to Netanyahu when
Manuel V is saying we're fighting
against jihadism and radical Islam which
is exactly the threat that Netanyahu in
Israel is facing and that is fled by
Maka. It just shows that even though
Manuel Bal said that the French still
don't have much of a clue as to what
they're dealing with. So you so you
think it's a really bad idea that they
both showed up at the same spot even
though it might sway some people to take
the political rhetoric the the uh
anti-ionist uh rhetoric out of the
discussion. Well, that would be nice if
that were to happen. But uh I think it
just obscures the issue. Makudabbas was
there to uh give himself a cloak of
respectability when if you look at what
he says and what his group, the
particularly the Satan movement, which
he is the head of say about killing all
the Jews, waging jihad against Israel
and so on and celebrating the jihad
attacks against Israeli civilians. uh
when he shows up at a uh site where the
jihadis had killed 12 people and then
they went and killed four Jews in a
kosher supermarket, it's hard to think
that he's really on the side of those
who are against that when that's the
kind of rhetoric encouraging that kind
of thing that he allows to be spread all
over the areas that he controls.
Robert, always a pleasure. Thank you.
Thank you. Robert Spencer joining us,
director of Jihad